hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es einen türkischen
nachtisch ich werde nämlich milchreis
machen
denk dir vielleicht auch milch reist wie
langweilig aber ist es gar nicht denn in
der türkei ist es wirklich so dass
milchreis zu den top sagt zu den top 5
der desserts gehört und zwar wird es
immer ganz traditionell im topf gemacht
und dann kommt es später noch mal in den
backofen wird also ein bisschen
überbacken und ich zeige euch da jetzt
mal meine version
normalerweise ist der milchreis immer so
süß ich mache immer ein bisschen die
zuckerreduzierte variante weil ich
einfach nicht zu mächtig haben möchte
ich brauche für den milchreis vier liter
wasser 100 gramm milchreis ein liter
milch
drei esslöffel stärke 150 g zucker und
etwas vanille extrakt ich nehme jetzt
den milchreis und den muss jetzt zuerst
einmal waschen das mache ich jetzt kurz
hinten unter fließendem wasser am besten
dafür in einem sieb geben und dann unter
klarem wasser abspülen unter kaltem
wasser abspülen dieses klar ist also
derzeit gibt mit der hand runter und
dann sieht man ja schon besitzt immer
noch trüb und ich weiß jetzt so lange
bis die stärke aus ist
dann kommen jetzt wasser und reis in
einen topf und zwar wieder reist erst
mit dem wasser weichgekocht hat
natürlich auch den vorteil dass nicht
überkocht und dass nichts anbrennt
jetzt schaltet den herd auf höchste
stufe last aufkochen
danach kommt der deckel direkt drauf und
dann stelle ich die hitze herunter und
lasst den reis komplett durch kochen
also durch jahren bei geringer hitze und
dann sagt er auch das ganze wasser ein
nach zehn minuten etwa sollte der reis
so aussehen also die flüssigkeit ist
jetzt komplett weg und falls noch rest
flüssigkeit da ist könnt ihr einfach den
deckel weg nehmen und bei geöffnetem
deckel noch ein bisschen weiter kochen
jetzt kommen die restlichen zutaten mit
dazu also die mädels da gebe ich jetzt
aber nicht komplett alles mit rein denn
ich möchte etwas milch mit der stärke
auch verrühren
dass die klümpchen frei wird das mache
ich jetzt hier in dem gefäß noch und
zwar sorgt die stärke jetzt gleich dafür
dass es später im backofen daneben auch
noch ein bisschen dicker wird als es
wäre schön cremig man wird zwar am
anfang die reißzwecken raus ganz komisch
aber durch die stärkung von innen schön
cremig jetzt stärke wieder mit dazu dann
auch den zucker also wie gesagt ist es
bei mir jetzt die zuckerreduzierte
variante ihr könnt auch immer selber
noch sagen ich gebe noch zucker mit dazu
oder lassen ein bisschen weg und dann
nochmal ne extrakt
und jetzt wird es noch mal aufgekocht da
muss man jetzt aufpassen damit auch
nicht überkocht wegen der mädels und
dass auch der topfboden nicht anbrennt
also jetzt auf höchste stufe stellen
einmal aufkochen lassen und dann nehme
ich die hitze wieder weg und lass es 15
minuten weiter köcheln
nach dem sitz 15 minuten leicht köcheln
durfte ist die konsistenz zwar immer
noch flüssig aber man sieht schon dass
sie cremig ist und der türkische
milchreis ist auch ein bisschen anders
als der typisch deutsche sage ich jetzt
mal beim deutschen reichs hat man
wirklich ganz viel reis mit drin das ist
auch eher fest und der türkische sind
eher so cremig und der kommt jetzt noch
in den backofen
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier offen feste
schäden habe ich mal drei große und
viele kleine unternehmen da auf jeden
fall schildchen die eben einen backofen
dürfen so die fülle ich jetzt etwa
randvoll
und den rest den ich jetzt fühle ich
ihnen normale sache also dass herr
schälchen und zwar um euch später zu
zeigen wie die konsistenz ohne backofen
ist also man kann es ja auch einfach so
lassen aber im backofen karamellisiert
die oberfläche noch ein bisschen
deswegen finde ich das richtig toll bei
den fans in dem backofen die habe ich
jetzt auf ein backblech gestellt und da
kommen wir zur noch wasser ins backblech
da müsst ihr aufpassen dass nichts eben
die schildchen gelangt und das war es
sollte so etwa bis zur hälfte reichen
das sorgt dann dafür dass die förmchen
auch genug temperatur abbekommen
jetzt kommt s 300 grad in den backofen
den vorgeheizten ziemlich weit oben in
der oberen einschub leiste und dann so
lange bis die oberfläche brown ist es
dauert etwa fünf bis zehn minuten
er sollte auf jeden fall ein bisschen
beobachten und danach lassen wir den
milchreis erstmal komplett abkühlen
vielfalt ist fertig und er ist auch
abgekühlt und der murat steht schon in
den startlöchern zum probieren ja
unbedingt dem rat mag kein mensch rein
aber ja ich mag es nicht meine mutter
ist dass kinder mit fast vergiftet
ja aber ich zeige euch jetzt mal die
konsistenz hier stützt der wildreis der
nicht im ofen war also noch ziemlich
wackelig und noch auch überflüssig könnt
ihr euch eigentlich auch zeigen
kennt ihr das wenn ihr als kind richtig
lecker derzeit richtig cremig und wenn
ihr mal als kind von irgendwas zu viele
hatte
was war es bei jedem schuss parieren das
war bei mir ist also dieser türkische
bulgur salat und ich konnte den
jahrelang nicht essen und nicht riechen
aber mittlerweile liebe die zuschauer
genau was ist hier nach west gibt ihr
euch auch so sagen gibt es irgendwas zu
viel hatte genau so und hier ist noch
hier ist die andere konnte ist das
andere schätzchen aus dem backofen
das ist etwas fester schon also wieder
mehr flüssigkeit verdunstet und ich es
ganz gerne mit etwas zimt max imdahl
ich mag es nicht gastro branche ok ich
probiere es jetzt ja und wenn du es
jetzt mag bestand so stolz und so zugeht
nicht wie ich es mag ja sagen ach könnte
ich das schon sehen was ich ja kalt also
morath marke eigentlich nichts was war
und was süß ist mein gott sind mir ein
früher sagt ich lege meine mutter nation
also ich glaube dann schmeckt es gut
dass ich alles politisch korrekt des
markts schmeckt gut
ja also ich mag sehr und ich probiere
das jetzt auch gleich eine kamera also
ich finde nicht mehr entspricht kann mir
schlecht
zumindest ist das ein richtig typisch
türkisches er auch zu ramadan zeit weil
man kann es halt richtig vorbereiten und
dann einfach in den kühlschrank stellen
und dann ist es eben bereit für abends
ich finde also man kann dazu noch was
säuerliches reichen so was wir ab
glauben so ist werde ich glaub ich doch
meinen aber weg der schon meine mutter
gelegen glaube ich kann es
vielleicht freunde stich hat auch mit
türkischen assets also der murat
überlegt jetzt wohl ist es so fertig
wahrscheinlich und wenn ihr das rezept
nach machen wollt geht auf sell ist da
stets noch mal ganz genau und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen bis zum nächsten mal
hier schmeckt echt nicht schlecht
deutlichkeit in deutschland sahen
irakkriegs die oder backofen dsds kennen
ok auf wiedersehen